slow motion rain to set the mood cliche
that's a horse on a boat right there
surely it has nothing to do with only an
illegal pirate things I did in the last
movie I think look for the groom to see
the bride before the wedding
would you movies please stop saying this
in everything wedding scene in every
movie ever created the wands the arrests
a Wong Williams kana this part is for
Elizabeth Swann you sailed here without
any knowledge that you needed to also
arrest Elizabeth Swann you have three
arrest warrants did you mistake the
other two for suggestions
the charge is conspiring to set free a
man convicted of crimes against the
crown of empire
I know news and general things travelled
slower back in the day than they do now
but how long has it been since the first
movie they just decided William and
Elizabeth were fugitives after probably
months and months during the time this
wedding was planned perhaps you remember
certain pirate named Jack Sparrow Katzen
flying bird signified a true cliche Jack
Sparrow is addictive Birds complications
arose ensued we're overcome must have
been a fantastic adventure too bad we
didn't get to see it what duties do keys
unlock things get to the goddamn
adventure already some of you've already
skipped to go long on this Saturday
Night Live skit thunder and lightning
let you know something ominous is coming
why is the rum always gone for sheer
shoutouts to the original movie I guess
and to what do I owe the pleasure Yule
carbuncle
he sent me no no she sent you and they
are not amused and he's not too happy
about that
and the idea when Jones might release
said terrible beastie
told you jack the time is off that's why
I waited down here for so long because I
knew you just randomly show up down here
we could finally have this conversation
it comes now drawn with ravenous anger
to the man what bears a black spot it
couldn't just come here right this
second because it's vacationing in
Mexico the Kraken will be drawn with
ravenous hunger to the man with a black
spot and anyone who wears the same hat
as the man with the black spot yes
Pirates of the Caribbean fans you can
relive all the greatest hits of the last
movie in this 150 minute extravaganza
how did Jack Sparrow become the leader
of this island people probably a good
story but we don't get to see it instead
the movie wants us to see the rather
unexcited adventure of how will tour got
to the island long sigh say eunuch e6
did that first movie was hilarious
save me um couldn't you've told me how
to do that before telling the natives
whatever you told them to take me away
right now leering rapey guys captain
captain jeez how long does it take to
stab somebody dudes been standing here
like that for 20 seconds no doubt you've
discovered that loyalty is no longer the
currency of the realm as your father
believes how does he know that she's in
here just because the box was obviously
opened that could have been her dad and
he doesn't even know she's escaped yet
Lizabeth Swan looks absolutely dynamite
for being a prisoner for so long did
they let her do her hair in prison and
why does she still have her wedding
dress on yeah it took Will Turner some
detective work to find the Black Pearl
it took these guys general paddling
around after escaping prison to find it
here the pella cost us believe the jack
is a God in human form they'll roast him
and eat him how long is this
relationship between Jack and the
natives been going on just long enough
for Will Turner to show up and save him
irony burger damn those assholes were
quiet come on man it'll take all of us
the truth aback Paul why would you say
this mom six foot two oh that's why oh
this guy had to run to the ceremony to
tell everyone about the prisoners
instead of just taking care of it
himself it's not like Will Turner on the
rest can get out of the cage so easily
this of course opens the door for the
Jack Sparrow escape
hilarious cannibal kid is so eager to
eat Jack he already has a knife and fork
out it's not adorable and cinebulle the
natives have been caught up to these
guys running in a cage yet good god man
I could have caught up to them from here
before these guys could movie steals
part of the opening scene from Raiders
of the Lost Ark also with the sheer
number of Spears being thrown and arrows
flung don't you think one of these guys
would have got shafted by now when we
last left Jack we saw a dude ready to
kick his ass hard instead he and the
others in the scene resorted to throwing
fruits and vegetables at Jack instead of
doing anything remotely logical they
understand this and then everyone
decides need to leave these prisoners to
go back to Jack who is still tied up and
can be subdued by one person but you
want me to feel like these characters
are in danger but this kind of stuff
proves they're never in danger
you might as well have shown Jack being
cooked and eaten and then have him find
a way to escape through the natives
digestive tracts I won't leave without
him perfect timing Jack who spends most
of his time drinking rum pirating and
whoring around Tortuga can somehow
outrun natives on their home turf but
only insofar as we keep the shallows so
the Kraken can't attack as long as
you're in shallow water then there was
no reason for you to even go to that
island if that's the case Elizabeth is
so certain the entire ship will believe
this dress's from a ghost she'll be able
to leverage the situation to go to
Tortuga that's our actual plan and it
works is a female presence amongst us
yes well the men they can feel it they
can probably also see the female
presence yeah this is like Clark Kent's
disguise to me this is the type of
stupid ship that makes a movie two hours
and 30 minutes oh and she's probably
naked nope because this is not the
Dangerous Method or Domino also probably
naked you give her credit for being a
stowaway but not clothe herself to blend
in that's the very question Jack once
asked it bad enough even to go visit her
oh no not her huh okay well that about
wraps up all the details I need to know
about this person also when we meet Tia
Dalma there is no danger or problems
that arise or anything she's nothing but
helpful where is the little person that
came along with them he was part of that
Hawaii as mine the boat chain just a
minute ago but now he's nowhere to be
found
Cobb Oh tomate yeah Kyoya not
and hand it just from the word Davy
Jones one weakness is buried exactly
like parallax Eva Jones cannot make port
cannot step on them but once every ten
years but why that's a completely
arbitrary rule and for how long can you
step on land an hour a day a year so
what's your plan man jack waits until
they get within sight of the Flying
Dutchman to ask will one's plan is also
either The Flying Dutchman is on shallow
water right now and Jack has completely
locked out or this movie has completely
forgotten that the Krakens ravenous
hunger should be leading it to the Black
Pearl since Jack still has the dark spot
on his hand barrel of oil is handy for
all your flaming sword needs okay so he
slices one of them but then he just
stands there for no reason after that as
if he's never seen anything unusual in
this series before how did this man who
cut his heart out become a squid lobster
hybrid I see the search for the female
stowaway on this boat frantically
continues I'm afraid sir Tortuga is the
only free port left in these waters hey
that's exactly where Jack Sparrow is
going no one sees this as a practical
joke or even looks up to see if anyone
could be controlling it it must be
ghosts what's that over that much of the
plot of this movie relies on people
being too stupid to breathe zini bar
fight I just wanted the pleasure myself
yeah that person who is obviously a man
is my kind of guy how does Mercer have
the obvious female is obvious detector
and every other man in this movie is
stupid as hell phantom of the Dutchman
why are all the crew of the Flying
Dutchmen heaping masses of peat moss and
aquarium decorations but Davy Jones and
the hammerhead dude are clearly the
results of Sid from Toy Story
successfully mating humans with sea
creatures 100 years before the mast
losing you uh bit by bit
and a microwave great explanation I
can't wait to hear about the becoming a
hammerhead process the key weight this
asshole can move get to work you lazy
bastard the Dutch name needs living hot
are there be no captain and if there's
no captain does no one have I get the
living hurt part but who cares if the
captain holds a key so the captain has
the key
oh you why did you even bother to come
out of the wall with useful information
if you weren't gonna spill all of it and
what were you afraid of anyway you're
98% boat at this point let me had to
find the man I love how does Jack not
recognize her voice you have news of her
was recently seen on the island to talk
to God why didn't he just go ahead and
capture them while he was down there he
didn't go alone did he he probably
sailed over in a ship with several
soldiers right wondering I was played
and Stan it's good that we'll knows but
does the audience know the rules of
liar's dice if you don't this next scene
is gonna make about as much sense as how
that one guy turned into a hammerhead
shark doesn't everyone know about it
what a wonderful world it is to be able
to walk into an unlocked cabin and find
the guy from whom you need to steal a
key sleeping upright this plan succeeds
just put as many leagues behind this as
you can damn is this the only boat
floating around in the Atlantic right
now is this ship called the coincidence
last time we saw the Kraken it buckled a
ship in two seconds now that will is on
the ship the Kraken attacks it's gonna
take its sweet-ass time why is it
picking up individual guys off the boat
and throwing them into the water it
could simply rip this boat in half and
sink everyone right now want awesome
destruction still way slower than your
average crack and destruction them how
did he get this far away from the ship
and being at man-sized flotsam also
managed to make it all the way out here
for will to save himself boys not here
he must be claimed by the same why did
you bother sending the Kraken to do this
job when you could have easily
transported yourself and your crew over
to the coincidence and got the key back
you had no problem doing that with the
Black Pearl earlier also you found the
coincidence with virtually no problem
and I was assuming it was because you
have some sort of magical attraction
toward the key but now you can't locate
Will Turner right next to you in the
water god I hope that's the last we see
of this fucking dress okay
to know what it tastes like teasing they
are here well it's a good thing you
decided to come here when you did
getting here pretty much the exact same
time they do you'll actually were
telling the truth I do that quite a lot
if people are always surprised with good
reason you did not hear that also Davy
Jones set the flying dutchman underwater
a minute ago and you were riding inside
that dragon mouth thing that must have
come up rather unexpectedly and I don't
know how you survived or got away
without being seen
look I want to kiss Keira Knightley too
but maybe this is the part where you
warned them about Davy Jones being here
instead of being such a selfish dick
dick I'm gonna kill Jones better do it
soon he's right around the corner right
right 17th century Reservoir Dogs also
why did Jack bring Norrington to the
beach he could have chosen any member of
his crew to help him dig but he picked
him because of the plot I guess I like
the cut of your jib lady when do we
start these two pirates decide to go
with a little used running out in the
open with stolen goods technique Hey
look the perfect castle on a deserted
island to swordfight it what are the
odds
also this castle comes complete with a
bell so the bad guys can find out where
everyone is it's like this church and
we're castle or whatever it is was built
specifically for an action scene in this
particular movie surprise asshole guys
wings to the left of Jack for some
reason and screams to give away his
surprise I know will taught her how to
use a sword and everything but when did
she become an expert who could fight
undead bad guys like she's been doing it
all her life why didn't this waterwheel
just steal Davy Jones's heart and board
the Black Pearl that obviously knows
what needs to be done for the plot oh
yeah the heart must be in that jar of
land Jack carries with him it's so
simple for me to figure that out
immediately just by looking we'll just
sit here while the fight rages on
somehow expecting not to get killed or
something oh I'm buck I need whoa this
guy is a dick to his head I'll just uh
since when do these two have the power
to relay orders on the Black Pearl going
for the slow death thing again I see
sure about 95% of the main cast is on
this ship why wouldn't you good thing
the Krakens tentacles line up perfectly
with the cannons
whatever you do done this good advice
why isn't the Kraken killing Jack right
now we were told that the guy with the
black spot on his hand was the one that
the Kraken has a ravenous hunger for
what the those tentacles must have
discovered the cure for being blasted by
cannon fire in two minutes flat
what the fuck is this dude doing on top
of this thing these tentacles randomly
grab everyone except people who are main
characters couldn't save anyone else
though could you how did he get up here
don't you need help getting on a ship
like this when you're on a small boat in
the water
well now should stop the kraken for a
couple minutes
I was just ship even still sailing after
all that nonsense we can get away as it
takes down the pub is Davy Jones even
watching any of this anymore you should
have caught up by now and the Kraken
should no sense see or feel people
getting on a longboat right
oh come on talk about inventing conflict
and of course this dickhead will lose in
perfect I saw you kiss another man
position talk do you not shit Q if the
Kraken was really after Jack it would
have taken that easy meal while he was
rowing by himself a minute ago
uh yeah davy jones's in this one of the
ships did pick up a line adrift to see
how did they find Norrington how did he
get into the water there were no boats
left behind when he was still on the
island did he build one in a week using
only a sword to cut lumber we found the
pardons but somehow didn't see the bag
full of heart he hid somewhere in his
raggedy clothes i took the liberty of
filling in my name damn this guard
escorted Norrington into this room
without a fucking sound there was
anything could be done to bring him back
would you do it I knew at World's End
was coming when this was released so
sure this isn't one bit of a surprise
but there's seriously a way to bring
someone back from getting eaten by a
Kraken Atwoods in role credit oh damn
got ahead of myself
Captain Barbossa was just sitting
upstairs waiting for Tia Dalma to spring
that surprise what if no one wanted to
save jack
would you just sat up there until they
left the director said let's have your
character eating an apple it'll make you
look like even more of a surprise
asshole happy ending for the dog I guess
only because the movie ends before we
see what really happens to him they eat
the leader right
you
food wise uh I can't believe they went
with the Frog ruin our audition was
flawless
so we did the look huh we get the tongue
thing mm-hmm
that was great frog show beard don't
listen to him Oh sad that I'm the Flying
Dutchman I'm the Flying Dutchman
I mean I think is something I must add
that Lady Catherine will apparently
approved for my speaker of your modesty
economy and other amiable qualities sir
I am honored by your proposal but I
regret that I must decline it I know
ladies don't seek to seem to EE mr.
Collins I am perfectly serious I would
cut off your head what if it stood but a
little higher from the ground would die
before your stroke fell the story opens
on a mysterious explosion
nobody knows what's causing it but it's
upsetting all the Buffalo so the
military are called in to solve the
mystery forgot yeah no no I'm saving
that my big underwater climate